.
WE SAW HISTORY TODAY.
HARRIS TAKES OVER NOW.
BYE-BYE.
>> Harris: COVID CASES RISING
IN OUR NATION AND MASK MANDATES
ARE MAKING A COMEBACK.
COULD WIDESPREAD LOCKDOWNS BE
FAR BEHIND?
I'M HARRIS.
THE DAILY AVERAGE OF COVID
HOSPITALIZATIONS IS BACK TO
25,000 AMERICANS.
COVID RELATED DEATHS STANDING
AT ROUGHLY 237 DAILY, DOWN
SLIGHTLY FROM JUNE.
STATES ARE SEEING SOME OF THE
HIGHEST INCREASES IN COVID
CASES, FLORIDA, ALABAMA, MAINE,
MASSACHUSETTS, AND NEW YORK.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALREADY
MANDATING MASK WEARING INDOORS
REGARDLESS OF VACCINATION
STATUS.
LAS VEGAS RECOMMENDING THEM
AGAIN AMONG OTHER AREAS.
AND TODAY ON CAPITOL HILL CDC
DIRECTOR ADDRESSED THE SPIKE IN
CASES AND URGED THOSE WHO
HAVEN'T YET BEEN VACCINATED TO
DO SO.
>> IN AREAS WHERE VACCINE
COVERAGE IS LOW, CASES AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE STARTING
TO CLIMB AGAIN.
THE MESSAGE FROM CDC REMAINS
CLEAR.
THE BEST WAY TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF COVID-19 VARIANTS IS
TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
DISEASE AND VACCINATION IS THE
MOST POWERFUL TOOL WE HAVE.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
DEATHS FROM COVID-19 ARE NOW
OCCURRING IN UNVACCINATED PEOPLE
>> Harris: THE AMERICAN PEED
ATTIC ASSOCIATION ALL CHILDREN
3 AND UP WEAR MASKS REGARDLESS
OF VACCINATION STATUS.
DR. FAUCI SAYS HE AGREES.
>> I THINK THAT THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS ARE A
THOUGHTFUL GROUP AND ANALYZE
THE SITUATION AND IF THEY FEEL
THAT'S THE WAY TO GO I THINK
IT'S THE REASONABLE THING TO DO.
>> Harris: SENATOR TED CRUZ,
REPUBLICAN FROM THE GREAT STATE
OF TEXAS IS IN FOCUS NOW AND
ALREADY SHAKING HIS HEAD.
LET'S GET YOUR TOP LINE
THOUGHTS.
>> YOU KNOW, AT SOME POINT
FAUCI BECAME A "SATURDAY NIGHT
LIVE" CHARACTER KA TOUR.
ENOUGH WITH THE MANDATES.
COVID IS A SERIOUS DISEASE.
VACCINES ARE IMPORTANT.
I'VE BEEN VACCINATED.
MY WIFE AND OUR PARENTS HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED.
IT IS A GOOD THING TO GET
VACCINATED.
BUT WE'RE SEEING BIG GOVERNMENT
STATES WHO WANT TO MANDATE
VACCINATIONS AND WANTING
SHUTDOWNS AGAIN AND MASK
MANDATES AGAIN, SHUTDOWNS WERE
A FAILURE.
THEY DESTROYED LIVES AND
BUSINESSES AND MASK MANDATES
DON'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
FAUCI AT THIS POINT NOW HAS
EMBRACED EVERY POSITION UNDER
THE SUN ON JUST ABOUT EVERY
ISSUE.
LAST YEAR IN HIS EMAILS AND
PUBLICLY HE WAS SAYING MASKS
DON'T DO EVERYTHING AND NOW HE
SAYS MASK EVERYBODY.
EVEN PEOPLE VACCINATED SHOULD
WEAR MASKS.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
WE NEED TO USE COMMON SENSE AND
COMMON SENSE DOES NOT ENTAIL
HAVING 3-YEAR-OLDS WEARING
MASKS AS WE'RE VACCINATING A
VERY SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF
OUR POPULATION.
>> Harris: SENATOR, THE WAY
THAT YOU JUST LAID THAT OUT
MADE ME THINK OF SOMETHING THAT
I HADN'T THOUGHT OF BEFORE.
IT IS ALMOST LIKE FAUCI AND
PART OF THAT GROUP THAT HE
CALLS THE BRIGHTEST AMONG THOSE
SCIENTISTS WHO ARE STUDYING
THIS AND WELL INTENTIONED,
WHICH IS ALL TRUE, THEY ARE
LOOKING AT THIS AND SAYING
LET'S PROTECT EVERYBODY WHO
HASN'T BEEN VACCINATED.
OUR JOB WAS TO PROTECT
EVERYBODY WHO HAD COMORBIDITIES
OVER THE AGE OF 75.
WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN DO
WITH THE BEST WEAPON.
THOSE PEOPLE HAVE MADE THEIR
DECISION NOW, MANY OF THEM NOT
IMMUNE COMPROMISED ABOUT WHAT
THEY'LL DO WITH VACCINATIONS
AND WHY YOU MADE YOURSELF
DECISION TO GET ONE.
LAST WORD ON THAT.
>> LISTEN, PEOPLE NEED TO
EXERCISE COMMON SENSE.
I BELIEVE IN INDIVIDUAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND FREEDOM.
AND SO CERTAINLY IF SOMEONE IS
ELDERLY AND HAVE HEALTH ISSUES
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO GET
VACCINATED.
ONE OF THE NEXT BATTLEGROUNDS
WILL BE VACCINATING KIDS.
WE HAVE NOT VACCINATED OUR
GIRLS WHO ARE 10 AND 13 BECAUSE
THE RATE OF SERIOUS ILLNESS FOR
CHILDREN FROM COVID IS SO LOW
THAT IN OUR JUDGMENT IT DIDN'T
MAKE SENSE AS A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS.
EVERY FAMILY OUGHT TO MAKE THAT
JUDGMENT BASED ON YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND LOVED ONES.
WHAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS TALKING
ABOUT WANTING TO END TITLE 42.
THE STATUTE THAT HAS ALLOWED TO
BE -- ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO BE
EXCLUDED DURING A PANDEMIC AND
THEY WANT TO RELEASE NOW
ESSENTIALLY EVERYBODY AND GIVEN
THAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING
CONSISTENTLY HIGH RATES OF
COVID INFECTION FROM ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS CONTRIBUTING
TO THE SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS BY
RELEASING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
AGAINST THE LAW INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IT IS DRIVING
UP THE RATES OF COVID
PARTICULARLY IN SOUTH TEXAS
ALONG THE BORDER.
>> Harris: IT SEEMS LIKE
INDISPUTABLE FACTS.
I DON'T KNOW YOU GET A DEBATE
ON THAT ONE.
YOU JUST HAVE TO COUNT, RIGHT?
WE KNOW OUR CAPACITY OF TESTING
RIGHT NOW.
WE CAN BARELY PROCESS THEM AT
THE BORDER YESTERDAY IN DEL
RIO, TEXAS, 300 PEOPLE FLOODING
IN FROM THE RIVER.
WE SAW THOSE PICTURES LIVE.
YOU BRING UP SUCH AN IMPORTANT
POINT.
I HAVE TO MOVE ON BECAUSE I
WANT TO COVER OTHER THINGS.
A LOT OF BACKLASH TODAY,
SENATOR, AFTER THE WHITE HOUSE
ADMITTED TO FLAGGING SOCIAL
MEDIA POSTS IT DEEMED
MISINFORMATION AS WELL AS
ASKING FACEBOOK TO HELP POLICE
THOSE FOLKS.
PRESS SECRETARY JEN PSAKI
DODGED A QUESTION ON THE
SPECIFIC POSTS AND IT WANTED
FACEBOOK TO REMOVE AND IF THAT
WILL BE MADE PUBLIC.
WATCH.
>> FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE NOT
ASKED FACEBOOK TO BLOCK ANY
INDIVIDUAL POSTS.
THE WAY THIS WORKS IS THAT
THERE ARE TRENDING -- THERE ARE
TRENDS ON SOCIAL MEDIA PLAT
FOEFRMENTS YOU ARE AWARE OF
THEM.
IT IS UP TO SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS TO DETERMINE WHAT
THEIR APPLICATION IS OF THEIR
OWN RULES AND REGULATIONS.
SO WE JUST CERTAINLY RAISED
WHERE WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
INFORMATION THAT IS INACCURATE.
>> Harris: I'LL ADD THIS QUICK.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WALKED BACK
THOSE ORIGINAL CLAIMS HE HAD
THAT FACEBOOK IS KILLING PEOPLE
WITH MISINFORMATION.
>> President Biden: FACEBOOK
ISN'T KILLING PEOPLE.
THE 12 PEOPLE OUT THERE GIVING
MISINFORMATION, ANYONE
LISTENING TO IT IS GETTING HURT
BY IT AND IT IS KILLING PEOPLE.
IT IS BAD INFORMATION.
MY HOPE IS THAT FACEBOOK
INSTEAD OF TAKING IT PERSONALLY
THAT SOMEHOW I AM SAYING
FACEBOOK IS KILLING PEOPLE THAT
THEY WOULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE MISINFORMATION.
THE OUTRAGEOUS MISINFORMATION
ABOUT THE VACCINE.
>> Harris: HE WENT BACK TO
BLAMING 12 PEOPLE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
ARE THEY KEEPING LISTS OF
AMERICANS THAT THEY THINK ARE
WRONG OR DON'T AGREE WITH?
CRITICS RIPPING BIDEN'S 180 ON
THE ISSUE.
ANOTHER, YOU SHOULDN'T TAKE ME
CALLING YOU A MURDERER
PERSONALLY.
ANOTHER ASKS, SO WAS THE
PREVIOUS STATEMENT
MISINFORMATION?
SENATOR CRUZ.
>> LISTEN T BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES IN
POWER.
THEY WANT TO HAVE THE POWER TO
SILENCE YOU.
SILENCE ANY CRITICISM.
FOR A POLITICIAN IF YOU COULD
HAVE ALL YOUR CRITICS SIMPLY
DISAPPEAR AND UNABLE TO
CRITICIZE THAT MIGHT BE PRETTY
NICE.
IT IS CONTRARY TO THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AND A FREE DEMOCRACY.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
GETTING BIG TECH TO BE THE ARM
IN SILENCING CRITICS.
BY THE WAY, WHAT THEY CALL
MISINFORMATION, VERY
CONVENIENTLY ALWAYS BENEFITS
DEMOCRATS, ALWAYS BENEFITS JOE
BIDEN.
THEY'VE BEEN WRONG OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY GOT BIG TECH TO SILENCE
AND DISAPPEAR TO BLOCK THE "NEW
YORK POST" FOR THE STORY ON
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP BECAUSE
IT WAS POLITICALLY DAMAGING TO
JOE BIDEN.
IT WAS TRUE BUT THEY CALLED IT
MISINFORMATION.
THEY GOT BIG TECH TO BLOCK
ANYONE SUGGESTING THAT THE
WUHAN VIRUS ACTUALLY CAME FROM
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT LABS IN
WUHAN.
NOW I THINK THE EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THE VIRUSES CAPED FROM
A CHINESE GOVERNMENT LAB AND
YET BIG TECH MADE THAT
DISAPPEAR AND ONE OF THE
STRIKING THINGS.
IT IS INTERESTING WATCHING THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE TRY TO BACK
STEP A LITTLE BIT FROM THEIR
STATEMENTS LAST WEEK.
BUT WHAT THEY HAVE
INADVERTENTLY DONE IS
STRENGTHENED PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP'S LAWSUIT AGAINST BIG
TECH, AGAINST FACEBOOK, TWITTER
AND GOOGLE BECAUSE LOOK, WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP ARGUES IN THE
LAWSUIT IS THAT THEY ARE
VIOLATING THE FIRST AMENDMENT
BY CENSORING AMERICANS.
THE BIGGEST ARGUMENT THEY HAVE
IN THEIR DEFENSE IS THEY ARE
PRIVATE COMPANIES, NOT THE
GOVERNMENT.
AND THE FIRST AMENDMENT ONLY
APPLIES TO THE GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS AN EXCEPTION TO THAT
THE SUPREME COURT HAS LONG
RECOGNIZED WHICH IS THE
GOVERNMENT CAN'T USE A PRIVATE
COMPANY TO CARRY OUT A
GOVERNMENT POLICY AND HERE THIS
IS WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
HERE THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE IS
ASKING THE BIG TECH MONOPOLIES
SILENCE, BLOCK ANY VIEWS WE
DISAGREE IT.
IT IS BLATANTLY ILLEGAL AND
ABUSE OF POWER THAT IS REALLY
CONTRARY TO THE PRINCIPLES THAT
OUR COUNTRY WAS BUILT ON.
>> Harris: WE KNOW THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING ON.
NO MATTER WHAT THEY SAY FROM
THE LECTERN BECAUSE THEY
ORIGINALLY TOLD US THEY GET
TOGETHER REGULARLY WITH THESE
BIG TECH CORPORATIONS TO TALK
ABOUT THE MISINFORMATION IN
FACEBOOK POSTS.
BY THE WAY, I DON'T KNOW IF WE
KNOW THIS AND I'LL JUST ASK
THIS RECEIPT TOREICALLY.
WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU GET ON ONE
OF THOSE LISTS?
I WAS POSTING ON MY TWITTER
LITTLE OLD ME.
I DON'T MATTER.
I'M NOT A BILL FACEBOOK USERS.
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WUHAN LAB
LEAK A YEAR AGO.
STICKERED, PROBLEMATIC.
WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU GET ON
THEIR LIST, SENATOR CRUZ?
HOW DO YOU GET OFF THE LIST AND
WHAT DOES IT MEAN WHEN THEY GO
AFTER THOSE 12 PEOPLE IF WE
CAN'T IDENTIFY THEM AS A
JOURNALIST I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE IF
SOMETHING GOES WRONG IN THEIR
PROCESSING.
>> THEY DON'T WANT TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
BIG TECH IS ASSERTING POWER
OVER ALL OF JOURNALISM.
IF THEY COULD THEY WOULD BLOCK
ALL OF FOX NEWS.
THEY ARE WILLING TO THROW
DONALD TRUMP OFF OF SOCIAL
MEDIA AND CLAIM COMPLETELY
UNACCOUNTABLE ARBITRARY POWER.
IF THEY CAN DO THAT TO HIM THEY
CAN DO IT TO ANYBODY.
IT IS AMAZING THESE SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS AT CNN, ABC, CBS,
"NEW YORK TIMES," "WASHINGTON
POST" WHO JUST MEEKLY GO ALONG
WITH A HANDFUL OF SILICON
VALLEY BILLIONAIRES, THE MODERN
OLIGARCHS.
LIKE THE RUSSIAN ONES WE HAVE
THE SILICON VALLEY OLIGARCHS.
THE MEDIA IS HAPPY TO HAVE THE
BILLIONAIRES.
THE SINGLE BIGGEST THREAT TO
FREE SPEECH AND DEMOCRACY IN
AMERICA.
WE NEED TO BREAK UP THESE BIG
TECH COMPANIES AND WE NEED TO
STOP THEM FROM CENSORING
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
THEY ARE OUT OF CONTROL.
>> Harris: LET'S GET TO THIS.
AN AIDE FOR SPEAKER PELOSI HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVID.
PELOSI STAFFER, THAT ONE,
HELPED USHER A GROUP OF TEXAS
HOUSE DEMOCRATS AROUND THE
CAPITAL LAST WEEK AND ANOTHER
ONE OF THOSE RUNAWAY TEXAS
HOUSE DEMOCRATS HAS TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID BRINGING THE
TOTAL NOW TO SIX.
MORE THAN 10% OF THAT GROUP
THAT FLED TO D.C. TO PROTEST A
REPUBLICAN STATE ELECTION
REFORM BILL, THAT'S A GROWING
NUMBER REALLY RAPIDLY.
LAST NIGHT 40 OF THOSE
DEMOCRATS HELD A VIRTUAL TOWN
HALL TO PUSH FOR A FEDERAL
VOTING LAW AND AGAIN PAINTED
THEMSELVES AS HEROES.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WE'RE SACRIFICING A LOT MORE
THAN JUST TIME AWAY FROM OUR
FAMILIES.
BUT ALL THAT SACRIFICE IS WORTH
IT.
IT IS WORTH IT TO PROTECT
TEXANS AND WORTH IT TO FIGHT
FOR THE AMERICAN DREAM.
IT IS WORTH IT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A FUTURE TO LEAVE
TO OUR CHILDREN.
>> Harris: A "WASHINGTON
EXAMINER" OP-ED SAYS TEXAS
DEMOCRATS CANNOT DO ANYTHING
RIGHT.
HERE IS THE QUOTE.
TO RECAP, TEXAS DEMOCRATS LOST
ANOTHER ELECTION IN 2020.
THEY FLED THEIR OWN STATE TO
PREVENT THE MAJORITY FROM
PASSING A BENIGN PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
THEY CHARTERED A FLIGHT THAT
THEY TOOK MASKLESS TO
WASHINGTON, THEN FIVE, NOW SIX
TESTED POSITIVE FOR THE VIRUS
AND ALSO EXPOSED THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
SENATOR CRUZ, THIS IS YOUR HOME
STATE OF TEXAS.
YOU HAVE SEEN WHAT I KNOW WITH
MY RELATIVES IN TEXAS WE DON'T
CUT AND RUN.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE HEARD SOME
REPUBLICANS ACCUSE THEM OF.
WHAT'S THE NEXT PHASE THEY ARE
IN NOW?
>> LISTEN, KARMA IS A
REMARKABLE THING AND THIS
EPISODE REALLY EMBODIES ALL
THAT'S WRONG WITH THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NUMBER ONE, THEY ARE WILLING TO
MANDATE RULES FOR ALL AMERICANS
THAT THEY IGNORE THAT THEY
FLAUNT THEMSELVES.
SO YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS EAGER TO
SEE MASK MANDATES ON EVERYBODY
WHO HAVE BEEN CHAMPIONS OF
LOCKDOWNS AND OF COURSE WHEN
THEY GET ON THEIR FLIGHT THEY
ALL TAKE OFF THEIR MASKS AND
END UP GETTING COVID.
BUT SECONDLY, THIS IS A
POLITICAL STUNT.
WE SEE THE TEXAS HOUSE
DEMOCRATS HOLDING THEMSELVES UP
AS THE HEROIC CIVIL RIGHTS
WARRIORS.
THEY HAVE LIKEENED IT TO THE
EDMUND PETTIS BRIDGE.
I GUESS THAT'S RIGHT IN PEOPLE
THERE STANDING UP TO THE DOGS
AND BEATINGS AND CLUBS WERE
ACTUALLY ON A PRIVATE JET WITH
MILLER LITE SITTING BACK IF
LUXURY.
IT IS A CITY POLITICAL STUNT.
THE LAW THEY ARE PROTESTING IS
A COMMON SENSE LAW.
IT IS THINGS LIKE SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION ON ABSENTEE VOTES
AND CAMERAS IN COUNTING ROOMS
SO YOU HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY.
BUT HERE IS THE GOOD NEWS,
HARRIS, THE STUNT IS GOING TO
FAIL.
THEY'LL RUN AROUND AND SPEND A
LOT OF TIME ON A LOT OF TV
NETWORKS GETTING A BUNCH OF
ATTENTION AND THEY'LL COME BACK
TO TEXAS.
WHEN THEY COME BACK TO TEXAS
THE GOVERNOR HAS RIGHTLY SAID
HE WILL CALL ANOTHER SPECIAL
SESSION.
WHEN THEY COME BACK THE TEXAS
CONSTITUTION IS CLEAR THEY CAN
BE ARRESTED AND IF THEY REFUSE
TO COME AND DO THEIR JOBS THEY
WILL BE ARRESTED AND PHYSICALLY
TAKEN TO THE FLOOR OF THE HOUSE
AND THE LEGISLATURE WILL DO ITS
JOB AND PASS THIS LEGISLATION
AND THIS POLITICAL STUNT IS NOT
GOING TO SUCCEED.
>> Harris: THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE STATE OF TEXAS, YOUR
HOME, KEN PAXTON TOLD ME LAST
WEEK ABSOLUTELY THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DO IT AND DO IT IF
IT'S NECESSARY.
THE GOAL ISN'T TO TAKE THEM TO
JAIL.
TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING THEM TO GO
TO WORK SO HE IS TRYING TO GET
THEM, AS YOU SAY, SENATOR, BACK
TO THE CAPITOL.
LAST THOUGH.
>> A BIT OF HISTORY.
IN 2003 I WAS A SOLICITOR
GENERAL OF TEXAS.
TEXAS DEMOCRATS DID THAT'S AS
WELL TO TRY TO STOP THE STATE
FROM DOING REDISTRICTING.
ONE OF THE FIRST QUESTIONS I
GOT AS SOLICITOR GENERAL.
CAN YOU ARREST FLEEING
LEGISLATURE?
I RESEARCHED THE QUESTION.
THE TEXAS CONSTITUTION
AUTHORIZES USING FORCE TO
COMPEL THE ATTENDANCE.
THAT LANGUAGE IS COPIED WORD
FOR WORD FROM THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION AND THERE IS
HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF PRECEDENTS
OF ARRESTING FLEEING
LEGISLATURE.
THE U.S. SENATOR, SENATOR BOB
PACKWOOD WAS CARRIED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FEET FIRST.
IT IS NOT ARREST TO GO TO JAIL
AND NOT TO GO TO PRISON.
IT IS TO MAKE THEM PHYSICALLY
PRESENT ON THE FLOOR SO THEY
DON'T GET TO STOP THE OPERATION
OF GOVERNMENT AND THE RULE OF
LAW.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE END OF
THIS.
>> Harris: OH LOT OF THINGS
OUTSIDE OF ELECTION BILLS.
YOU ARE TRYING TO REVISIT THE
GRID ISSUES THAT YOU HAD
PROBLEMS WITH IN THE WINTER
THAT FROZE AND YOU HAD TROUBLE
FOR CITIZENS THERE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS TO
GET TO RIGHT AWAY.
SENATOR TED CRUZ, ALWAYS GREAT
TO HAVE YOU